justicia para pancho piden familiares y
amigos del joven malabarista que murió
por disparos de un policía en
panguipulli en el sur de chile
el cuerpo de la víctima fue llevado
hasta santiago donde decenas de personas
se reunieron para rendirle un homenaje
era un buen chiquillo
[Música]
él
estaba sentado con
él no molesta a nadie
podría ser
de los días pero sin casi nada
los hechos ocurrieron el viernes cuando
el joven se resistió a un control
rutinario de la policía lo que derivó en
un altercado con uno de los agentes
quien le disparó en varias oportunidades
el uniformado fue puesto en prisión
preventiva y el caso es investigado como
un homicidio con arma de fuego el vídeo
del suceso publicado en redes sociales
enfureció a una población que ha sido
testigo de reiteradas denuncias de
brutalidad policial muy buena persona
merece marinas
- por alguien que debe brindarle
seguridad institución carabineros de
chile
[Música]
el caso trajo nuevas protestas a las
calles de santiago en un llamado que
urge a reformar el cuerpo de carabineros
señalados de hacer uso excesivo de la
fuerza y cometer violaciones a los
derechos humanos contra los
manifestantes durante los últimos años